Speakers. And we will now be going
to the City Council. Yeah, one of the,
I would say being biased, one of the best departments.
So at this time, I want to welcome Ms. Bernita Jones to
provide the administrative office of City Council budget presentation
and shout out to her whole new staff because she has a
new staff with a lot of friendly and new faces.
So thank you all for being here. Look forward to your presentation.
It. Welcome, Miss Jones. And the floor is yours.
Oh, all right, thank you.
Get a break.
That's a R.
Thank you. Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Bernita Jones. I'm assistant director
for Houston City Council. And today I will be presenting
the FY 23 projected budget for City Council.
But before I start, I would like to introduce my staff to you.
On my right I have Mary Hamilton. He does the financial analyst
for City Council. And if my new staff will please
stand, I would like to acknowledge them. These are the individuals
that take care of city council every day. They make sure
that all of their needs are met. They work really hard and they
always have a smile on their face regardless of what's going on. And I would
just like to thank them. I appreciate each one of them.
Next slide, please.
Right here are 16 council members that
are overlooking the beautiful city of Houston,
Texas. And I would like to acknowledge
the council members because every Tuesday constituents
come in and they just hammer the mayor and the
council member. And I would like to say that these City council member works
very hard. They work hard and they're diligently looking after the
city. They have CIP meetings, they have civic
club meetings that they attend. They have town hall meetings. And they
do a great job in making sure that the City of Houston is
the best that it can be. And I thank each council member for the hard
work that you do. Thank you. Next slide, please.
Okay, now this is the organizational chart for the City of Houston.
And in FY 22 we
had approximately 78.4
I can't see the screen 78.4 FTEs.
In FY 23, we're proposing
to have 79.5 FTEs.
And as you can see, the budget for FY 23 is
proposed to be $13,985,308
for City Council as a whole. The budget as
you go down, you will see, will be split between 16 council members and
that would be $491,115.
A little
further, you go down and you see city council general. That's $627,466
which is allocated for the health funds and the health insurance for
city council members and their staff. The last allocation is for
council district service funds. That's $5,500,000.
Next slide, please.
Next. We have the gender and the ethnicity, the demographics
for City Council. There are 53 females and
26 males that's working with City Council. And ethnicity.
We have 29 white, 29 black African American,
18 Hispanic Latinos and three Asian Pacific
Islanders. Next slide, please.
And right here I'm going to do a comparison and I really
want to break it down because I want to make sure that we're open and
everybody understand exactly how city council budget works. So I
tried to break it down a little further on this slide to kind of explain
exactly how it is. Our adopted budget in FY 22
was $13,604,307,
and that was split between
the office at $468,915.
So as you can see, the FY 22 operating budget
was $7,502,640.
This is the money that council members use to
pay their staff for services and for office
supplies. It all of this comes from their
operating budget. So you make sure you understand that's what that is
for. Then you have the council district service fund, which is 5,500,000,
and the health benefits that I told you about earlier,
that is how we comprise of 13,604,317.
If you were to look at the budget book today, you will see that council's
budget seems to have increased, but it has not.
Literally, it hasn't. It is 15,000,508 $193
as of today. And the reason for that, as you can see,
we had restricted accounts, a credit of 5609.
We had a Hope adjustment of 3%, and that was 130,480.
And then we had a council
district fund carry forward over of
$1,779,005.
I want to explain the carry forward for you in case some people
may not understand what this is. In FY 21, all of the
council funds and the projects that were requested.
As you know, sometimes it takes a lot to get these
done, and I want everybody to know that the council members work
diligently. We have a process. First of all, it has to be reviewed by
legal and then the administration has to approve it.
So sometimes it takes a little longer for these projects to
go into fruition. So if the project has been reviewed by
legal and it has been approved by the administration,
but we have not purchased the items yet or they have not completed it,
those funds can be rolled and forwarded and carried over.
So that's why you have a carry forward of 1,000,007, seven,
nine, five. And that is why the budget looks like it increased
at the present day. Next slide, please.
So for now, we are projecting to have $13,985,308
in city council's budget, and that comprises again of
the operating budget,
$7,857,842.
Council district service fund,
5,500,000, and health benefits,
$627,466.
Next slide, please.
These are the It. As I stated before that a lot
of times it seems as if the budget is big,
but council member budget is mainly staff and driven
by it. That is why these are here to show you some
of the It driven costs that you will have application services increased
by 30,657. And any hits questions,
I would ask that you would direct that to hits, because these are the numbers
that I received from the It department.
Data services decreased by $11,283.
Voice services decreased by $3,244.
Voice labors decreased by $509. Next slide please.
Egis revolving fund service decreased by $25.
Voice Services wireless increased by $3,192.
Chronos chargeback increased $247.
Next slide please. Overall you
can see as I stated early,
91.39% of
city council's budget is allocated to personnel.
And then you have 7.28% which is in other
services and charges. And out of the services and charges,
78% is hits related charges,
1.29% is supplies, and then you have 0.4%
for equipment. Next slide please.
So this is Council District Service Fund. Carry forward over from FY 21.
As I stated before, there's 1,779,000
worth of council district service funds that we had to carry over
that were not completed in FY 21. We are
proposing what we adopted 5,500,000 for FY
22. As of today, we don't know how much will be
carried forward to FY 23. We will know that amount on June 30.
When the fiscal year ends, we are projecting
to get another 5,500,000 in council district
service Fund for FY 23.
Next slide please.
Right here are major projects, and I just want everybody
to know that we have approximately 350
to 400 council district service projects that
are performed annually with this money. And on here,
I just basically put the major
projects, projects that are very expensive and
a lot of funding is needed for these. So they have increased
from last year. As far as major projects. On these two pages you can
go through and see all of the major projects that the council members are doing.
And as I stated, these projects are really
important things to the city. That's why I say these council members are
working hard. We go through legal. I know there's been a lot of talk about
council district service funds, but legal reviews
them, the administration approves it. We make sure that
all contracts are accurate before we
do any work with any of these major projects or any projects.
Next slide please.
This is a slide of the priorities and initiatives that
the council members have stated are their top two.
These are the top two, they have several, but this shows by
district which initiatives they have stated to be priorities,
initiative as their top two. And the next page shows
the at large council district service funds,
council district members. These are their priorities and their initiatives.
Next slide please.
Looking at this, you can see that $4,743,915
are allocated to HPW, that is the council district's service
fund, and it is broken down based on how much money we allocated
in FY 22 for these projects.
So HPW and HPD are the most ones that
council district service funds are allocated to. Next slide
please. Appendix and then in the appendix
we have the restricted accounts, because as I stated,
hits restricted accounts really has a major important part
in the council members budget. Thank you for your
attention. Are there any questions for me at this time? That was
such a great presentation. You do an excellent job,
you and your entire staff. Thank you. Council member
Cayman.
Ms. V, thank you for everything. You're welcome.
And to the new staff, welcome. We're so
happy to have you. And, of course, Miss Love, thank you for always
being there.
You do so much for our offices,
from our budget meetings to, again,
tracking, I think you said over 400 projects
that we're each pushing through all of the time. So,
again, huge appreciation to your office in terms
of needs that you see either for your office specifically
or as council, what do you foresee in the coming
future as some of those needs? So I have conferred
with several of the council members, and I do know that they
are short staffed and the needs that they have in their office,
if they could have more staff members, because right
now they are stretched pretty wide based on all
of the work that's going on in their offices. And there are minimum four
to five staff members in every office, and the need to
have more people in their office would be great. And I've always said
that the council district service fund is great, and they've asked for
more because they can't complete all of their projects because they're
kind of waiting toward the end because they don't have enough money to do all
the things that the constituents are asking for.
I certainly echo the need for more staff,
I think our council staff and a huge thank you to all of our council
staff. We did a tally in a poll of
our district, most, of course, per usual three
one one calls, but also most calls of a district office.
I don't know how my staff does it, but they're incredible. And we could always
I think I speak for every at least district office of we could
always use and at large. Okay. And at large, we can
always use more. Just so, Ms. Vernita,
for the public's knowledge,
the council members, our salaries
are not set by the city, is that correct? Yes.
Your salary is based on the judges at the county.
And in terms of I mean, we're covered by
insurance and things like that. But as
council members, we don't have things like FMLA, is that correct? That is
correct. But we were able to get, at least for our chiefs of staff
that had an exception previously, coverage for paid parental
leave and other benefits. That is correct. Okay. I just wanted that
to be clear. Thank you. Okay, thank you.
Council Member David Robinson. Yeah. And just to build on that question,
the recent Hope adjustment, ms.
Jones, if you could comment on that, how that affected the salaries
of our staff and for that matter, council members, if you
could. I'm sorry. The hope,
the city employment, the home contract
yes. And what was the question, if you
could state out loud for the record how that affected our staff and our
personal salaries. So what happens is the
increase is 3% and it is based on an average of
the council members in their office. And because council members
have to have the same budget, we average out the highest office
and whatever that is times 3%, that is determined how
we allocate the 3% and that increases everybody's
budget the same. Thank you. But the council members do
not get a 3%, right?
Correct. That's what I wanted to hear. Thank you.
Well, thank you again for your presentation. Thank you to your entire staff.
We lean on you all for so much and kind
of the backbone of our offices, which are extension of
all of our constituents in each district and at large.
So thank you again and you are dismissed. Thank you.
We will now move on to the public comment
period. We will start with the virtual public speakers.
Please press star six to unmute when your name is
called and the first name is ms.
Saba Blandy. Good afternoon again.
I had a question, a couple I was curious, what is
one piece of information you would most like
to know if you were able to survey every single one of your constituents
and what do you think are the most effective efforts to engage your
constituents in your district? And I'm just curious if anyone
has some new efforts planned for the coming year?
Okay, I'm going to ask you, Ms. Blanding, to repeat that a little slower one
more time. Oh, man, I'm sorry, Councilman Member
Pollard, I was trying to go slower. Okay. I was curious what
one piece of information you would most like to know if
you were able to survey every single one of your constituents?
I was also curious what you think are the most effective efforts to engage
your constituents in your districts. And I was also curious what
are some new efforts planned for the coming year?
Okay, so for my office, and I know for everyone,
it's probably different, but one piece of information I
would like to know is how they feel about our constituent response
times when they reach out to our office, either by telephone
or email. Do they feel as if their issues and concerns are
being addressed promptly? I think the best way to
engage the constituents is by showing up in person, whether that's an HOA
or a civic club. But people like to see you active and in person.
I think it's a great way to develop relationships and also a great way in
which to communicate and understand their needs from the grassroots
level.
Anyone else in the horse you want to chime in?
And your third question, Ms. Blanding.
I was just curious if anyone had some new efforts they wanted to try this
year in terms of engaging constituents.
If anyone had some new ideas, what ideas do you
have?
Oh, well, I mean, I always
think efforts to to provide surveys are good, and I know traditionally there's
club engagement, but as much as I can engage here,
civic club, my husband has a meeting every month for
our civic club. So I was just curious what you all like to try.
I think most of us like to get a lot of our ideas from the
public. We really work for you. So many of the times that you see us
responding to issues or concerns is based on
your engagement. So it would be great to hear from
you as a constituent, what ways in which you think we can
better communicate and collaborate with you and
the community. So if you have
an idea or something you would like to share, maybe even not today,
but feel free to email us if you have ideas on ways in
which we can best communicate and engage with you going forward.
Absolutely. I appreciate the invitation. You're welcome. The next
speaker, Ms. Barbara Herndon.
Barbara Herndon, please press star six to unmute.
Amanda Shy, please press star six to unmute.
Hi, and just briefly, my last name is
she. Thank you. Thank you for your time today.
So many of the other departments have
metrics or outcomes outlined in the budgets that they
publish. So as representatives of constituents,
do you all have target metrics? What do you consider outcomes?
And then I have another thought, which is
that the slide 15 in terms of the distribution of the CDSF
funds, that was really helpful. As a constituent
of District I, I would just like to express that I'm interested in seeing more
funds allocated for Case Education, Do,
N, and HPL, all departments and programs that have expressed
unmet needs throughout these presentations. So I'll return to
my question, which is basically, what are some target
metrics and outcomes that you
all have in mind?
So as it pertains to metrics, I can speak for the District J office.
What we like to do is put out initiatives and projects and ideas
that we have many times that are brand new, and then we
have to wait and see what the outcomes are. We're really a
results based office. And so whether it's with
supplemental trash or a District J Patrol program, new initiatives
that are just now coming to the district, many times it's
going to be based off the feedback, the engagement, how many people are
receptive, and responsive to the things that we're doing, the feedback that
we hear at the civic clubs and the HOA meetings on if it's beneficial
or not. Do they believe it's something that they
want to see their tax dollars spent on? And for
most of us, I think that's how we are able to gauge if a project
is worthwhile going into the next budget
year to fund through our council district service funds going forward.
And was there one other question that you may have had.
That was my main question. Do any of the other council members
want to share?
None at the moment, because I think we're running behind on
time. But I'm sure if you reach out to your
individual district council member, they will collaborate with you
going forward. But thank you for your questions. Next is
Jason Oliver.
All right, if you'll indulge me, I want to start off just by really
I really appreciate CDSF and these presentations
because I know that you all create a lot of these programs
directly in response to what community members are asking
for. So some of the ones I'm excited about and glad to see, a lot
of the trash pickup and drainage work, the Senior Development
Boys and Girls Club and District K,
the Public Safety, the more expansive public safety,
street lights and sidewalks stuff happening in District F,
seeing some of the Vision Zero. And then the
WiFi access is huge in District H,
there's a lot. And then the community beautification work
that's happening in district, just some of the ones that kind of stuck out to
me that I really wanted to highlight. And now to go into my
questions. So first,
where are we in terms of the impartment inspection reform?
Just curious about that project that I know we've heard about over the years.
And then second, does any district and this goes into Council Member Pollard's
question about engagement with constituents.
Does any district have good resources or processes explaining
how the CDSF works to constituents,
explaining how it works, what projects are proposed and eligible,
and the process for submission? I think CDSF is a huge opportunity
to widen the net of how people know about what
the district is doing and then really getting engaged in that process of
directly participating there. So, yeah, that's my idea
for engagement. So regarding the apartment inspection
ordinance, that is something that's pending at the moment. I know that Council Member Leticia
Plumber is taking the lead on that. And so those
discussions are still ongoing on the best considerations
for that as it pertains to the council district service
funds. Many times what we do is we reach out to all of our
neighborhood associations and stakeholders within the community and
ask them what do they like to see regarding if
it's improved parks, if it's improved
infrastructure, do they want to see more police presence? So every
community and district is unique and has its own dynamics. And so
many times the requests that come into our office for things that they want to
see, we prioritize. And then those are what we spend the dollars on
through our council's funds.
Council Member Cayman Jason, to your question about outreach
in terms of determining some CDSF, I know multiple council
members, including my office, have started even doing surveys
on social media. So, for example, we fund air monitors that
are publicly accessible information. But where they should go up we put a
survey out, we ask for suggestions, and the locations
are being determined based on that. I think it's a whole combination of things.
Council member newsletters always open to more information,
but you are asking some really important questions.
They're directed, I think, to all of us. But I think the best way to
get some of those responses or provide your suggestions is to individually reach
out on that and also know that we leverage
a lot of our dollars. So even though we get a
million dollars, 500 for mobility and then 500
for just general operating projects in our
district, we leverage that money with the management districts,
with our Turs, with our county partners. So we try to find outside
dollars, even from the private sector to partner with. So we
may be able to turn $100,000 allocation
into a $400,000 allocation just by working with other
entities that have similar interests in what we're trying
to do. So we appreciate all the constituents
feedback on ways in which we spend your tax dollars.
And if there's particular projects and initiatives that you see in your
community that you like and you want to advocate for
going forward, please do. And if there are things that you don't like or that
you think are not beneficial that we're spending your tax dollars on, let us know
that as well. And that completes our public
comment period for the City Council presentations.
And now we will move on to
welcome director Tina Pius and Valerie Berry
to provide the And Regulatory Affairs budget presentation.